what is the relationship between the
circumference of a circle and its area
okay well I can consider the area of
this circle has made up of an infinite
series of infinitesimally thin
circumference is Right Watch okay first
you've got the circumference it's
already there okay so it's two pi r in
length just by definition my 2 pi is
just the number that we designate that
cuz it's the ratio between the
circumference of the diameter okay so
you've got one there right now if you go
a little bit smaller you'll have another
circumference that has a radius well
that's smaller the sarcastic conference
is 2 PI R like less than that and then
you get one that's a smaller again it's
smaller again it's loading it and
eventually somewhere you will eventually
get a circumference which has well has
no length it's of zero like okay so you
have this infinite series of
infinitesimally thin circumference ins
okay all right now how will I add all of
these things together when the answer is
I want to integrate them right like so
what are the things what's the function
that I'm adding up and the answer is I'm
adding up a whole bunch of circumference
is ok now you remember over here we
usually talk about this is like a little
width DX that's where it started from
but do you remember that I said I've at
properties of definite integrals right
then when you have a definite integral
this X it's just a dummy variable it's
just kind of standing here there's a
number right it's not really like it's
not that important what this thing is it
can be anything right so this thing is
actually not changing with respect to X
there's no X in there in fact ok what's
really changing with respect to is the
radius right like you've got the biggest
circumference which has a radius bar and
then you have the smallest circumference
which has a radius R 0 right like it's
it's in comp watch was no space it's
just a point ok so therefore we know
that what you start with your lower
boundaries where that radius is 0 right
and the upper boundary is where the
radius is the whole size of the circle
mainly ah ok so when you look at this
this is just a function it's just a
polynomial right all you have to do is
the power thing right so you say what's
the primitive of 2 PI R and you draw
your knowledge you raise the power you
raise the power to two and then you
divide by that power right and then
you've got your lower and upper
boundaries there ok but of course a
couple of things cancel don't fear you
are actually evaluating it at two
boundaries so what you're getting into
pi r squared take away 0 ok that's
really where this comes from you're
doing more than just you don't have to
Adam rectangles you can add up circles
if you want you don't even have to add
up things of like these are these are
all one dimensional quantities ok I just
you can see there if the tests with you
okay I can add up things with more
dimensions example this is a while so
i'm going to show you this morning
there's so many more ok Archimedes I can
be smart guy he was the guy who worked
out as anyone know he's thankful ok this
screw is imported videography he's
famous for is the under they fire number
writes the Eureka moment isn't it right
he's trying to work out like volume and
displacement of water and so on ok he
thought a lot about born I can be sort
of what about more you write one of the
things he determined was if you have a
sphere brightest feed you want to know
how how big is the area around the
sphere really really clever he worked
out that if you've got a silly law right
which has the same dimensions as the
sphere namely it's the same width and
it's the same height then very
interesting way you can always visualize
that this is the case the current
surface area of the cylinder will be the
same as the surface area of the sphere
that's pretty cool right I'm you can
almost imagine unwrapping like tick like
a like say al you know a tin of like
canned food right and then you unwrap
that thing they are just the wrapper ok
and if you cut a whole bunch of lives in
here you could place them around here
and then you would fold them up and you
would entirely in case the sphere ok so
he worked this out now just really
quickly what is the
surface area of this cylinder ok
remember I'm just starting with any
Eddie Eddie sphere right so let's give
it a radius of our ok so therefore i'm
getting at all the same dimensions on to
hear right so I've got the radius of our
here now how I work out just the curve
surface area what numbers do I heat ok
very good I need this Dylan yeah you're
right you're right i need the hype
obviously ok now because it's got the
same dimensions as this fee are the
height is going to be our up this way
and I of that down that way so this is
to our to agree with that and then
remember I told you you you start up
unwrap your tin tin's food right and
what you get is a rectangle right how
why I've already went out how high how
why does the rectangle yeah it comes
from unwrapping the circumference right
which is 2 pi ah so you get the surface
area in green here which says same as
the surface area of this view you get
that surface area as 4 PI R square
because to R times two PI R right now if
what I want to work out this volume in
the same way that area is just like a
whole bunch of an infinite series of
infinitesimally thin circumference a--'s
bowling if you imagine like one of those
are Russian dolls you know those
babushka dolls where they just made up
of a whole bunch of like smaller and
successively smaller goals in there and
it fills up the volume so ball you
really is the sum of an infinite series
of infinitesimally thin surface areas
right like those shells and they get
smaller and smaller and smaller so
therefore what I'm integrating the thing
that I'm adding up and combining into a
whole are a bunch of surface areas right
and they are changing with respect to
our ours the thing that's changing is I
go from that smallest stops area to the
biggest one that's on the outside the
smallest one has a radius of 0 and the
biggest one has a radius of our so you
just do your normal thing and you say
well what's the primitive function of 4
PI R square and you take the power up
right 23 then you divide by that power
and you evaluate it at upper and lower
balance
which unsurprisingly is that stinky
little formula which you've learned for
so many years and not know where it came
from okay so here's my point right
indefinite integrals right we go toward
indefinite integrals because you don't
just need them to be attached to this
simple problem just like this is not
just attached to light right this says
you know what out of anything you like
combined anything you like I believe it
when we combine a lot of different
things right that's why we're going to
look at in definite integrals right it's
the same problem as finding the printed
so bless you when all that work that you
spent anti differentiating right and
finding the primitive we can now import
it's literally exactly the same skill to
integrate something when it has no
boundaries that's all you need to do
okay so in fact some people read you
know if I said to you this right
internet x squared with respect to X
okay you can literally read that is tell
me the primitive function of x squared
which of course is remember we're
integrating not differentiating right so
this is how it goes up / the power don't
forget the concert okay yes okay very
good so because in a definite integral
the reason we don't need to worry do you
remember the reason we don't need to
worry about a constant because it gets
added and then subtracted so it just
vanishes away whatever about this value
is ok but an indefinite integral it
doesn't do that adding subtracting theme
so the constant is still there okay and
now is the perfect time to actually tell
you right when we learnt about the
primitive function we said it has 10
plus it because there's a whole family
of them right but now that you know it's
also attached to the process of
integration this see on the end its
proper name is the constant of
integration
imagine so now it gets a name because no
you know how it comes about right it
wouldn't have made much sense of size
because of integration when you didn't
know what an integral was but now you
okay fun times okay one last thing I'm
going to mention which is just a side
note and you guys know I actually hate
having this conversation but it's
important for you to know anyway the
custom integration as you can see it
actually represents not a trivial thing
irreverence do you understand the
difference between these two things and
why there's like a whole family of these
right so it's important however is you
make what we have imagined right in a
typical exam paper you're going to be
calculating like five or six or seven or
more of these indefinite integrals which
means there will be five or six or seven
or more spots where you need to put a
causative integration ok now we're not
going to pin you every single time if
you forget to write the cost of
integration on your whole paper what
will happen is out of those five or six
or seven questions we will pick one of
them I will say okay that question if
you leave off the constant integration
even though it's like oh it seems like a
minor error you will lose an entire mark
right one hallmark on that I should let
you know it kind of does stand out
because when you see a question like
this right this is a one-bar question
really like there's not much to do here
if you see this questioning it has two
bucks on it kind of bit of a city now
you should always have the see you
should always have the same okay but
this will explain why you might you
might think I'd such a little thing how
about is a whole mark for it and the
answer is we are only checking for it
once if you make the same error five or
six or seven times you know we'll only
worldly penalize awards but we have two
pillows somewhat because it represents
an understanding does that make sense